alright guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
veronica success we're gonna watch the
trailer for but i think has really
inspired our relationship fifty shades
of grey
granted i never read the book but from
the few things I know about it I think
it could help improve our relationship
in a lot of ways I don't know what it's
about
it's about a lot of sex I've gotta read
this book you have to read this book we
got to read it together we could get the
audio tape and just listen to it
together the whole time I like reading
it it makes it more of an authentic
experience
well whatever helps you feel a better
baby okay so let's watch this trailer
I'm trying to say I want to have more
sex be you ready baby I'm ready it's not
so appropriate actually less sex has
nothing to do with sex
so what was he like mr. grey will seen
he was really smart very intense to what
do you owe your success I've always been
good at people I have a natural instinct
for what makes it personal tact
Anastasia
Christian to complication pre-med so
much
be free I like to see your face
kiss me so cool what you might be
thinking see you a control freak
hey exercise control in all things must
be really boring No
not playing fair this is like our story
look in that for you well you let me you
know then I had a rough start in life
that's all you need to know
my tastes are very a while singular you
wouldn't understand
like me then why are you trying to
change me but not that you're the
cheating me I can be with in the way he
needs me to
say I did stay but what happened
like the song sexy huh really sick
really sexy huh you turned on a little
bit a little bit I really want to read
the flick last time I saw the trailer I
think I said this it does remind me of
Twilight in some aspects you know you
got this guy who's like magical and then
you got this girl who's normal
and she's kind of you know depressed and
some [ __ ] and then he's like oh I'm so
fascinated with you for some reason I
don't know why but maybe there's a good
reasoning but the movie looks like it's
executed well it looks like a like a
like a sexual thriller that we haven't
gotten in a long time you know like the
Michael Douglas days yes uh quite a
twist when I saw that he was into
dominatrix submission yeah you know how
Sikhism yeah the whippin the violent
type of stuff that I've been trying to
get you to try to get you to we're not
talking about this right now the acting
looks better than Twilight not to just
compare this whole movie to Twilight the
Acne looks good too I mean the thing I
feel is most neat is actually the one
thing I think anyone's mentioned the
cinematography looks great it looks like
beautifully captured the whole time
which makes me just want to watch these
guys have sex you didn't know this is
cinematography mmm
no I was too distracted by the sex yeah
that's a sexy [ __ ] treatment
[ __ ] sex um I don't recognize those
two actors no should we it's like you
know like when you watch porn it's
better to watch it when someone is not
you don't recognize the props but it's
always as an actress this kind of gives
me hope whenever I see someone lead in a
big feature like this point they're to
me they're unrecognizable but they're
not like huge film stars and very
liberties is Desa I get what you mean I
mean I'm impressed with a guy I mean man
is just a trailer but you know it does
take a certain level of confidence in
yourself in order to play a guy like
that who you know everyone thinks is
super [ __ ] sexy unless you know he
was just born that way knows how
good-looking he is I mean I like the
shots of his six-pack did you like those
shots yeah yes nice right there all
right I mean they were all right yeah
who's kind of skinny what
are you just saying that cuz I'm here no
you're lying no it's the under you're
lying no I like men six-packs well I
like thicker guys I like the like no no
he's kind of skinny okay fair enough
yeah I mean the girls pretty you know if
she seemed I could actually see a more
personality to her that I could possibly
gather why this guy is drawn turd yeah
I'm excited to see the dominatrix action
really excited you know like so excited
I think it's gonna do pretty well well
it's a huge [ __ ] book yeah yeah I
mean I've heard a lot about it I hear
it's like a porno a lot of people who
read the book say it's like reading an
erotic novel awesome I know right we got
to get on this baby got to maybe we will
get it we'll get it on audio and we'll
get it in book form yeah and then we'll
watch the movie naked well let's just
buy all the tickets in the theater and
then we'll just take off her clothes and
watch the movie okay but we're not doing
anything I want to feel the temptation
you know what I mean all right guys
thanks for time yes miss met us this
trailer was out I've been horny so this
is good if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects bad
guys subscribe was good yeah yeah well
we keep it real and veronica has a
channel too where she does a lot of
covers and vlogs and she'll be posting
more original music soon so check that
she isn't out very beautiful voice part
of the reason I fell in love with her
and plus I'm gonna write off her fame in
the future
Joey traversée hey I would like a
shout-out for my youtube channel JW j
wits with that's with a z22 gaming he
does um erotic dances on his channel
it's very misleading his people think
it's a gaming channel but Joey actually
is an erotic male stripper and he's
trying to promote himself blurs out the
penis cuz it's YouTube it's really sex
game it's really sex games we're shining
him out on the right video ya know it's
like he gives you you look up his videos
if you want to learn how to do sex games
and he teaches and demonstrates for you
yeah yeah and he does all kinds of crazy
I mean the dancing is incorporated dan
the dancing is part of it but I'm
telling you like he does but stuff to
himself oh good job doing Anthony fig
ololo right and you probably missed me
so may I have a shout-out please thank
you Anthony fig you know Anthony
my brother's name so you're all right
and fig is um things are good
figs are good you know there's a story
in the Bible where Jesus was like whoa
whoa whoa does that fig tree have any
figs and they were like no then he's
like get rid of the fig tree then true
story true story
you know so if a fig tree doesn't have
figs get rid of it Anthony I used to
steal things from my neighbor's tree all
the time she didn't like it
mmm but they were so good hmm I used to
come on my neighbor's lawn Oh huh just
to get back at them but surprisingly and
me their plants grow extremely fast drew
love hey Ryan you probably don't
remember me but you gave me a mention
not a shout-out a while back while I was
a pretty new subscriber I felt like
trying to get a hold of you again
because after viewing your video with
Alyssa to this day project I admire you
and the other rejects a lot more I just
want to let you know that you are all my
role models and I look up to all of you
oh you need better role models don't
remember how I found you guys but I'm so
glad I did because you guys make me
smile when I feel it's impossible -
thanks rejects you know we call
ourselves the rejects my friend my
friend drew love because you know we
know what it's like to be an outcast to
be a reject we do so you're you're
you're part of the rejects now drew love
we're an odd bunch you know this is
right dr. Drew Pinsky dr. drew from love
wine oh well dr. drew you're welcome
you're welcome dr. drew I know you
mainly get your career thoughts and how
you've been able to go far in life drew
was mainly because of us so thank you if
you ever need anyone to talk to
any advice come to us you come to us
thanks dr. drew and you can come to us
before you go to bed - drew no I mean
I've gotta get that